and there's tyler mcgill's uh numbers uh
1-0 i mean the mets have won five of his
six starts here's the one-two pitch
swung on and missed strike three side
retired so old mr calm and cool beats
riley with a slider let's see if max can
have an uneventful brisk crisp first
inning and set the tone on the mound
yeah it'd be nice two starts against the
mets this year one on one with a two
four five two balls and two strikes on
brandon nemo on the pitch on the way
curveball got him looking strike three
that was beauty
that completely froze nemo now agrees
here's the 3-2 on the way
fastball got him looking strike three
that painted the corner
and alonzo not so sure
but right out of the gate freed really
enjoying malachi moore's strike zone
so two out two on you got the pitcher
coming up but mcgill is hardly out of
the woods yet because max freed is one
of the best hitting pitchers in baseball
and he struck him out with the fastball
second strikeout for mcgill and he
strands a pair in the second inning no
score
one ball two strikes
from max freed
and underneath his glove dansby 360 spin
makes a nice play
max freight unhappy he didn't catch that
himself but dansby johnny on the spot
he's got an impressive run with the
glove at shortstop that's one of those
where the ball's not hit real hard and
kind of just hopped up on max but
dansby great play times it perfectly
with the turn
and throws a beautiful strike to freddy
close play
did they get him
yeah they called him out
[Applause]
i just saw the outbeat put up on the
scoreboard
reminder we are broadcasting remotely
and relying on the
yeah it looks like freeman's tag pushed
his hand off the bag so they are picked
off
and that brings alonzo up with two men
on
and he takes one the other way for a
base hit mcgill lumbers to third he's
going to have to stop there
as peterson gets it in so alonso goes
the other way and his base it loads the
bases from mcneil well pete is really
really
focused
on the opposite field and sometimes you
know with that ball's inner half when
you're facing the tough pitchers
you know you hit your situational hit
that's a good charge by
by jack peterson but you got a pitcher
on second it doesn't run well
kind of tough to drive him in with a
single here's mcneal
with the bases loaded and two down
that's a three hits and a walk in this
inning with the pick off looming large
and he takes one the other way past
riley base hit mcgill is in nemo will
stop a third and the mets have the lead
jeff mcneal wasting no time slashing one
the other way another big hit for mcneil
to give the mets the lead it's one
nothing new york well i'm glad to see
jeff using the opposite field it's an
rbi situation
and
almonte playing real shallow and nimble
who can fly had no shot it gives mcneal
a 15-game hitting streak as he continues
to extend the longest streak of his
career and that was enough to get mcgill
home
2-2 coming freeman foul tips it for
strike three
good high heat from tylor mcgill to get
freeman
six strikeouts for mcgill
got freddie to chase out of the strike
zone good high riding fastball riley has
struck out and popped out he's got a six
game hitting streak on the line tonight
[Applause]
swing and a drive straight away center
at the wall it's gone
riley comes through and ties the game on
a two-strike homer to straight away
center
man oh man did the braves need that
lightning bolt in the sixth
they try to climb the high fastball
after all those changeups and austin
continues to stay hot and deliver 106
off the bat dead center
42nd game for for trevor
and he has pitched well of late
1-2 coming and her radio foul tips it
for strength three
high heat from trevor may and he strikes
out his first batter
one down in the seventh
tragozi swing and a miss and kevin smith
is down on strikes so may has retired
his first two batters both via the
strikeout
knocks freed back to the mound for the
bottom of the seventh facing the lower
third of the mets order jonathan vr
leads off
swaying and a miss
strikeout number eight on the breaking
ball for free he has set down five
straight getting stronger as the game
goes longer one out and now brandon
drury will be the pinch hitter batting
for may drury is five 5-5 in july
1-0 dreary hits one in the air deep to
left field this one's gonna go home run
brandon drury he does it again off the
bench and this time it's a breaking
homer
drew is third pinch hit home run and the
mets have taken a two to one lead here
in the seventh so second and third one
out in the eighth two to one new york
one and two the count
now the pitch
check swing he went around strike three
the slider in the dirt familia gets him
a huge strikeout for the second out
runners remain second and third
and dansby swanson will be the batter
and it's grounded toward the hole moving
over his vr the throw to first is low
but handled by alonso side retired
strong work by jayrus familia to get
riley and swanson and leave the tying
and lead runs in scoring position
hanger and he missed it
shallow center heredia streaking in
slides and he made the catch
wow how did he get there
ray's been playing very deep this entire
series and heredia had to
turn on the afterburners to haul that
one in for the first out well it's tough
already i felt like played shallow a few
times he got burnt now he plays deep and
a big guy like alonzo obviously with a
big swing
great job concentration with ozzy right
there too
he is
fine on the mound now preparing for the
ninth inning with the mets leading the
braves 2-1
and a shot into right-center field
that's going to get down for a base hit
it's going to bounce over the fence
for a ground rule double
so
the braves have a shot lead off double
to start the top of the ninth inning so
now ay ray adrianza will be the pitcher
banning for kevin smith adrianza started
in right field last night and reached
base three times on a double walking hit
by pitch
and now diaz is trying to seal the deal
after a lead-off double
adrianzo though lines one on the right
for a basement almond in a third waves
home here comes conforto's throw to the
plate mccann the tag he's out
he's out
put the tag on the sliding al monte
to keep the tight run off the board
they will review it yes
they will definitely review but the home
plate on fire malachi moore said that
mccain got the tag
on el monte as he slid by
they will check with the replay center
he made contact with him he got him
before he hit the plate
he's out yes he is no
he is out wow what a clutch throw by
conforto
and the replay center confirms it and
they're a two down in the ninth
3-2
in the air left center long one pia lore
and again makes the catch and the ball
game is over
diaz hangs on conforto with a big
outfield assist brandon drury's home run
puts the mets in front to stay and the
mets win a thriller from the braves to
even up this series of two games of
peace as the mets win it 2-1